bien mes chers
amis merci de d'être venu nombreux pour
ce conseil national si important pour
notre famille politique je sais que vous
aviez de nombreuses occupations dans vos
fédérations et votre présence témoigne
de votre attachement à notre famille
politique à la préparation de
l'alternance j'ai vu certains d'entre
vous arrivé du la Corse la Fédération de
la Corse bien s mes amis au Marnet mais
je vous demande d'applaudir nos amis de
Nouvelle-Calédonie nos amis de Wallis
Futuna nos amis des Antilles ma chère
Sonia qui sont parmi nous
aujourd'hui je veux saluer le président
de notre mouvement Nicolas
[Musique]
Sarkozi
c'est que le
début notre secrétaire général éic vert
bris
ortefeu Isabelle lecalénec notre délégué
général vice-présidente notre trésorier
Daniel Fasquel nos secrétair nationaux
membres de l'équipe dirigeante Alain
Joyandet conseiller politique Roger
carouci Brigitte Custer notre
porte-parole pierre Lelouche Françoise
grostet Philippe Meunier et George fenc
voilà alors mes chers amis avant de de
démarrer nos travaux je voudrais vous
dire quelques mots sur le déroulement de
cette journée je vous disais que ce
conseil national est très important
parce qu'il correspond finalement à
l'aboutissement de 18 mois de travail
acharné et je veux vous remercier vous
les conseillers nationaux vous les
secrétaires nationaux les parlementaires
qui avvez travaillé pendant des mois 18
conventions organisées rue de Vaugirard
avec l'intervention de plus de 300
experts extérieur avec à la fin de
chaque convention à la fin de nos débats
la préparation d'une quinzaine de
propositions par grande thématique ce
qui nous a permis de rédiger un
document
celui-ci qui vous a été adressé par mail
il y a quelques jours et que vous avez
trouvé en arrivant ce matin c'est un
travail important aujourd'hui parce
qu'il va nous permettre de sélectionner
parmi ces nombreuses mesures
l'architecture
l'ossature de notre projet pour
l'alternance alors je souhaite que cette
journée soit un petit peu à l'image du
Conseil national que nous avons vécu en
février c'est c'est-à-dire le plus
interactif possible nous avons nos
experts nous avons nos secrétaires
nationaux qui ont participé à
l'élaboration du projet mais vous êtes
là les uns les autres vous avez votre
mot à dire vous avez des propositions à
faire vous avez des témoignages à
apporter donc tout au long de la journée
nous alternerons les prises de parole de
nos référents de nos secrétaires
nationaux des parlementaires et les
prises de parole des conseillers
nationaux que vous êtes c'est cela aussi
le nouveau visage des républicains cette
interactivité ce parti qui est capable
de donner la parole à
[Applaudissements]
tous enfin avant de céder la parole à
notre trésorier je voudrais juste
apporter une précaution pour nos débats
mes chers amis les Français nous
regarde nous devons aujourd'hui incarner
une espérance pour nos concitoyens la
France souffre la France va avoir besoin
des républicains et nous avons un devoir
aujourd'hui c'est de débattre devant eux
de débattre de manière adulte de
débattre idée contre idée projet contre
projet d'être capable de s'écouter
d'être capable de se respecter tout au
long de la journée parce que oui les
Français nous regardent alors je sais
vous avez sur vos
préférences en a qui sont plutôt Girou
il y en a qui sont plutôt Gignac il y en
a qui sont peut-être cabaille et
d'autres qui sont Canté il y en a qui
préfèrent peut-être Pogba et d'autres
ont une sélection dans leur poche mais
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous dans la
même équipe et de grâce pas de but
contre son
camp
alors je vais céder la parole à notre
trésorier Daniel Fasquel qui va nous
faire un rapport financier vous en avez
l'habitude puisque c'est le Conseil
national le Parlement du parti qui
délibère sur ces questions et Daniel
vous proposera également deux petites
modifications de nos statut que nous
aurons à ratifier par vote à la fin de
son intervention Daniel c'est à
toi